5 26 on your monday morning got a heads  up about losing some daytime freeway  lanes in henderson nevada department of  transportation taken away the right lane  of both directions on i-11 between  horizon and college now that's not a  huge stretch but the hours of the  closure 7 a.m to 5 p.m today tomorrow  and wednesday wow that could add brake  lights and headaches to both the morning  and afternoon rush hour you're also  going to be losing the right shoulders  of the freeway ramps at horizon and  college good news the guard rail  painting they're doing as part of the  final phase of upgrades to this part of  i-11 if you didn't quite catch all this  or maybe you just want to go over it all  of our driving you crazy stories are on  our 8newsnow.com website when you click  traffic then driving you crazy buckle up  drive carefully please put down that  phone something's driving you crazy  email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com